but we're going to begin with the
breaking news overnight the kind we
always hate to bring you you know how
this is going there's been another mass
shooting in America now this time it
happened on the campus of Michigan State
University at least three people were
killed and five more were wounded police
say the suspect seen here during the
attack is dead and they have not
released his identity and there's no
motive that we know of so far Roxanna
siberi is in East Lansing Michigan where
the campus is located Roxanna good
morning a lot of us woke up to this news
this morning
good morning Gail it is another tragic
story the suspect has been identified
only as a 43 year old man around 50 000
students are enrolled here and last
night many fled or boarded themselves up
in their dorms as law enforcement tried
tried to track down the shooter
This truly has been a nightmare that we
are living tonight police say the
nightmare began just after 8 15 P.M
Monday we have multiple victims at this
time dispatch audio reveals the violent
scene as the gunman appeared to move
from room to room in a building on msu's
campus I have so far is that there's a
shooter in the hallway 135 who are
jumping out of a window currently
terrified students appear to run for
their lives chaos and confusion spread
across the campus as local state and
federal law enforcements swarmed the
massive University everyone's freaked
out everyone's terrified I see these
people running in my direction and I
Sprint I'm jumping down flights of
stairs around an hour after the shooting
was first reported police said the
suspect was believed to be on foot at 9
26 PM they reported a second shooting
location later confirming the incidents
occurred at Berkey Hall a social
sciences building and then at the nearby
Student Union roughly three hours after
the first shots were reported University
Police released these photos of the
alleged gunman described as a short
statured black male wearing a jean
jacket red shoes and a baseball cap
about an hour later police say the
gunman shot and killed himself at an
off-campus location clear mail not
moving
um GSW land here after police determined
there was no longer a threat to the
campus msu's interim president offered
an emotional message to the community we
won't take two days
where we will move to emergency
operation to give ourselves time to
think and to grieve
and to be together and this Spartan
Community this family
will come back
classes here are canceled for the next
two days we spoke to students last night
who said even though police say the
gunman is dead they were still too
afraid to sleep in their dorms some
checked into a local hotel and others
went home to their parents Nate
Roxanna thank you